moment qui sera le meilleur de bernard
de la villardière j'appelle en premier
jean-luc de la villardière bonsoir je
suis un boulogne billancourt france est
si vive tenta c'est ce qu'on appelle
dans le jargon télévisuelle des
chroniqueurs badauds pas d'eau potable
pas de lunettes dans les toilettes
il y dans des conditions d'hygiène
déplorables c'est en tout plus d'une
trentaine de personnes qui essaient de
se disputer neuf places autour de la
table certains ont fait la photo et
n'ont jamais vu le plateau kouba
manigances vols dans les loges ce soir
je vous propose une immersion dans les
coulisses de tpm paix web
[Applaudissements]
jean-luc à bosser tout le week-end à on
était sur son émission qui va arriver
il fixait le roi ça va être énorme béret
et la coiffure c'est en fait des tubes
avantage bravo jean luc oursel va en
faire des caisses à gilles de la
villardière s'est passé
bonsoir bienvenue dans enquête exclusive
mais s'est avéré télévision combien
coûte un programme
quels sont les animateurs qui gagnent le
plus et surtout à quoi sert christophe
beaugrand aux usa
allez on enchaîne tout de suite avec on
veut enchaîner tient avec non on va pas
les mettre tout de suite oui on va
mettre monsieur gilles moindrot maxime
de la villardière bonsoir et bienvenue
dans quêtes exclusives à numéros ce soir
consacrée à l'amour au programme d'essai
de rencontres des clubs échangistes et
des journalistes magicien qui ont choisi
l'abstinence
bonsoir
voter pour le meilleur bernard de la
villardière sabote sa botte ça va aller
on à kelly de la villardière c'est parti
auj
bonsoir et bienvenue dans enquête
exclusive alcool sexe et orthophonie
bienvenue en immersion dans le monde
jean michel maire la crise a fait jean
michel bérard à ce qu'on appelle une
jean michel maire allez on accueille
tout de suite à valérie de la
villardière
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue dans
enquête exclusive
nous sommes ce soir au cap d'agde pour
enquêter sur un des loisirs préférés des
français et de gilles verdez le
naturisme une enquête au plus près de
l'arrêt
[Applaudissements]
du coup kelly réellement la spat sa mort
d' affaire d'état
et on va on va accueillir et on finira
par les deux plus âgés
on va accueillir rokhaya de la
villardière c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
calais en direct beaucoup bonsoir et
bienvenue dans enquête exclusive
ce soir vous découvrirez comment quand
on est titulaire de plusieurs masters
dont un en droit international et
européen qu'on a été animatrice pour
mediapart est accepté on en vient à
imiter
bernard de la villardière sur ces mines
a tenté tmt
allez
c'est un master master man les plusieurs
endroits des master en droit
ouais c'est pas vrai et oui telle
qu'elle barre toi c'est ta fais tu as vu
correct avec mention mention bien oui
mention bien
mais à peine de taper tout est ici comme
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à l'est on accueille tout de suite
agathe de la vie à redire
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans enquête
exclusive
au programme ce soir naufrage fiasco
descente aux enfers l'avis de bruno
guillon depuis sa reprise d amour au no
[Applaudissements]
c'est la fuji bernès à décoller allez on
va finir par les deux personnes on en
trouvera trois balles et trois personnes
c'est vrai car si jean luc hallé on va
accueillir tout de suite belge a pas de
la villardière
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans enquête
exclusive
ce soir mariage divorce et surtout
pension alimentaire et millions s'envole
jamais retrouvée plongée au coeur de la
vie de benjamin castel hall d'accueil de
suite
isabelle morini bosc qui s'appelle
[Applaudissements]
début les lambeaux jamais il n'est pas
dépressive tu nous as fait une encre et
là sur la tête de ma mère me roger
[Rires]
ouégnin va devoir faire jean michel tu
vas te calmer et dis moi tu vas au bol
d'or cette année
merci alors d'accueil de but jean-michel
de la villardière
[Applaudissements]
enquête exclusive patois bienvenus
bienvenu ce soir dans enquête exclusive
[Applaudissements]
document choc sur le milieu des grands
restaurants français un milieu jusqu'à
présent épargnée par la constitution et
la drogue et la cocaïne mais pour ce
même temps encore un document signé tony
comiti pour guère décisive at il a bossé
la beauté il a bossé la ville tony
comiti c'est bien connu quand c'est pas
nous c'est assez bas qui s'ils allaient
ou d'accueil de suite isabelle de la
villardière la dépression
c'est plutôt bon soir et bienvenue dans
enquête exclusive ce soir la découverte
de la cuisine la gastronomie italienne
carbonara pizza et panna cotta
car l'italie ont lem quand on l'a bien
en bouche vers le samedi le dimanche et
intérêts par exemple on assiste et on
assistait de trois ouvrages